[Music]
i love her beauty but i fear her mind
[Music]
our true passions are selfish
[Music]
if you don't love me it does not matter
any way i can love for both of us
[Music]
a novel is a mirror walking along a main
road
faith i am no such fool everyone for
himself in this desert of selfishness
which is called life
there are as many styles of beauty as
there are visions of happiness
[Music]
god's only excuse is that he does not
exist
[Music]
it seems that my destiny is to die
dreaming
misery destroys judgment
[Music]
the first instrument of a people's
genius is its language
[Music]
there is nothing so beautiful lovable
and moving as the english countryside
[Music]
old age is nothing but the absence of
madness the loss of illusion and passion
love is a beautiful flower but we must
be brave enough to pick her up from the
edge of a precipice
[Music]
i cannot provide the reality of events i
can only convey their shadow
[Music]
a very small degree of hope is
sufficient to cause the birth of love
[Music]
your career will be a painful one i
divide something in you which offends
the vulgar
prestige sir is it nothing to be revered
by fools gaped at by children envied by
the rich and scorned by the wise
but if i sample this pleasure so
prudently and circumspectly it will no
longer be a pleasure
[Music]
indeed man has two different beings
inside him what devil thought of that
malicious touch
[Music]
it seemed to julian that there was far
too much air in his wig
[Music]
they can only touch the heart by
bruising it
[Music]
julian felt himself to be strong and
resolute like a man who sees clearly
into his own heart
[Music]
after moral poisoning one requires
physical remedies and a bottle of
champagne
the more one pleases every body the less
one pleases profoundly
[Music]
the boredom of married life inevitable
destroys love when love has preceded
marriage
[Music]
i am mad i am going under i must follow
the advice of a friend and pay no heed
to myself
[Music]
it was the destiny of napoleon would it
one day be his
[Music]
there's one convenience about absolute
power that it sanctifies everything in
the eyes of the people
what woman alive today would not be
horrified to touch the head of her
decapitated lover madam
[Music]
pleasure is often spoiled by describing
it
[Music]
in love unlike most other passions the
recollection of what you have had and
lost is always better than what you can
hope for in the future
it is something like love at first sight
an instant reveals to you what your
heart had needed for a long time without
recognizing it
power after love is the first source of
happiness
[Music]
i do not feel i have wisdom enough yet
to love what is ugly
the pleasures of love are always in
proportion to our fears
[Music]
love is like a fever which comes and
goes quite independently of the will
[Music]
one half the finest half of life is
hidden from the man who does not love
with passion
in paris love is born of fiction
[Music]
it is better to have a prosaic husband
and to take a romantic lover
the less you have sex the more
inspiration you get for great songs
[Music]
according to stendala takes about a year
and a month to fall in love all being
well
people happy and love have an air of
intensity
friendship has its illusions no less
than love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you